David, we good? Alright,
Welcome everybody.
We're gonna open with a worship psalm,
so we'll sing together that'll, uh, warm our hearts to
what God has for us from his word tonight.
So let's go ahead and sing.
This is a song,
um, that we'll enjoy together.
You wanna stand? Yeah, let's go ahead and stand everybody.
And
Beautiful. You
all can have a seat.
Does everybody have a sheet with class notes on
It?
Alright, well welcome tonight.
Uh, my name is Ryan Whitaker.
If you don't know me already, um, I've served here
as an elder for the last four years
and my family, uh, has been coming to Henderson Hills for
over 16 years now.
And, um, we love this church.
We love this church because God is exalted in all
of his attributes here
and that song is just full of how good he is.
I've been such a recipient of God's grace in my life and so,
but it's really good to see you.
Thank you for coming out on a Wednesday night
and we're gonna dig deep into a lot of things tonight.
And so before we get going, let's go ahead and pray with me.
Go ahead and back your, your eyes.
Father, you are holy, holy,
holy God.
Your word says that you dwell in inapproachable light
and yet you make yourself known through Jesus.
Forgive us that we have, uh, often
small thoughts of you
and that we trade your glory for lesser things.
God, we see in your word that you are the giver of every
good gift to us.
We thank you for your spirit tonight.
Our spirit remakes us to reflect your character.
So God, we pray that you would open our eyes tonight
as we lift up these truths, uh,
from your word you have given to us.
And so we ask that you would shape our worship,
you would shape our holiness
and you would shape our love so
that others would see your beauty.
We ask these things in Jesus' name. Amen. Amen.
Alright, I have a question for you.
So what comes into your mind when you think about God?
What comes into your mind when you think about God?
What I say A song. I'm sorry,
What? I, Isaiah a
saw
And what did he see?
Just filling up the hole. Yeah.
Where it was, yeah.
Recognizing how unclean lives he had. Yeah.
I love that
Greg said, it is so beautifully.
Thank you, Greg. The answer to your question about
what you think about God is the most important
thing about you.
What do you think about that for a second?
A w Tozer has a quote where he says,
what comes into our minds when we think about God is the
most important thing about us.
And I don't think that he's exaggerated.
So if your vision of God is small, then your worship
of God will be small.
But if you see him as he really is, that he is holy
and he is loving
and he is wise,
then your whole life is reordered
in awe and in worship and in obedience.
And that vision that you behold of him in that it transforms
everything two
Corinthians three 18 says,
and we all with unveiled faiths, behold the glory
of God are being transformed into the same image from one
degree of glory to another.
And so what comes into our minds when we think about God is
the most important thing about us.
Tonight we're talking about the communicable attributes
of God, and that is a, uh, theological word,
but here's what that means.
These are attributes that God shares
in part with us.
And I want to thank Dan. He's not here this week, um,
but last week he took us
through God's incommunicable attributes.
And can anybody remember any of any of those?
Which ones? Do you remember which stand?
Which stand out to you? Incommunicable attributes.
Holiness. Holiness. What else?
I'm just guessing. Omnipresence,
Omnipresence, ent, omnipotence.
What else?
Immutability. Oh, that's a beautiful one.
In the Old Testament,
before God's commands came, the people dealt
with fickle, unpredictable gods
meaning they change.
And you could, you're, you're always in fear of
what is this God going to do to me?
And God's immutability should be a comfort
to us and should be.
So yeah, all of those are incommunicable attributes.
And so unlike God's incommunicable attributes,
like his infinity or his immutability
or his omnipresence, Communicable attributes are ones
that we can reflect.
So think about that, that God invites his children
to look like him.
That's a pretty special thing. So let me ask you this.
Why does God share his attributes with his people?
Why does he share his attributes with his people?
Here's the big idea, and you see this at the top
of your sheet, says, God shares his attributes
with his people so that we can reflect His
what His glory.
He shares his attributes with us so
that we can reflect his glory.
And that matters for three reasons. Number one, worship.
It matters because when you see who God is, you
adore him.
And we'll talk about this verse a little bit more later.
This is the memory verse that we have
for tonight's Exodus 34 67.
Listen to this. The Lord passed before him Moses
and proclaimed the Lord, the Lord a God, merciful
and gracious, slow to anger
and abounding in steadfast love and faithfulness.
He can steadfast love for thousands forgiving iniquity
and transgression and sin.
But who will by no means clear the guilty.
Now listen carefully to verse eight. Jump to verse eight.
After Moses hears all of this, Moses quickly
bowed his head toward the earth and he worshiped.
So when you see who God is, you adore him
and you worship him.
So it matters because of worship matters,
because when you imitate his attributes,
you grow in holiness, which is our sanctification.
So it matters because of our sanctification.
Leviticus 19 two says, you shall be holy for the Lord.
Your God is holy.
One Peter one 16, you shall be holy. For I am holy.
Ephesians five, one, therefore be what?
Imitators of God as beloved children.
So it matters for our sanctification.
It matters for now our witness.
It matters because when others see his attributes in you,
they glimpse him.
They glimpse him. Matthew five 16 says this,
in the same way, let your light shine
before others so that they may see or get your good works
and give glory to your father who's in heaven.
Then John 13 34, 3 5 says,
new commandment I give you
that you love one another just as I've loved you.
You are also are to love one another.
By this, all people will know that you are my disciples.
If you have love for one another.
God is glorified as we worship,
as we're sanctified, as we witness.
So here's how we'll walk through this tonight.
First, a quick explanation of
what communicable attributes are,
and then second, we'll talk about the attributes themselves.
We'll group them into categories.
A lot of books
and theologians will group them in different ways
and label them in different ways.
And that doesn't matter a whole lot.
But for the purpose of tonight, uh,
we're I think using primarily the book Bible doctrine,
we will follow that list as the book has for simplicity.
And then we'll ask what so
what, like what do we do with this?
So now that we have a vision of who God is
and his attributes, how does that affect our Monday mornings
as we get ready for the week?
Or how does it, how does it change how we talk with people,
how we interact with people, how we relate to others?
And even how, how should it steady our boat when the waves
of suffering come to win?
And then we'll close with a memory verse and a prayer,
and then I'll hand it off to David for discussion.
So when we talk about communicable attributes,
we're asking this simple question of how is God like us?
How is God like us?
And a better, a better way to say that is,
how are we like God?
That's the better way.
And these are the perfections of God in his goodness
that he has chosen to share with us his people.
And that doesn't mean that we share them in the same degree
or the same level of perfection
that he embodies these attributes to be.
It's far away from that actually, this last Sunday, I,
I was hanging out with my 9-year-old nephew, Grayson,
and we were parked in the parking lot just over there.
And I was waiting for Noel, our daughter,
to get out of Bible study.
And so I'm just having a conversation with Grace,
and I asked him, I said, I said, you know, when,
when my parents, uh, uh, the biggest thing
for my parents and their wife was, uh,
man stepping foot on the moon?
And I said, for me, in my generation,
probably the biggest thing is the invention of the internet
that changed everything.
And I said, I asked Grayson, I said, in your nine years,
like what is the biggest thing that's happened in your life?
And he thought, for about 20 seconds, I love people
who are able to just like sit in silence
and think for a while.
He sat in silence for about 20 seconds
and he said very clearly, he said, he said, there was a man
who set the world record
for the most number of hot dogs eaten.
And and so
inside I am dying laughing inside.
Uh, but outside, I'm, I'm considering that to him
as if that's, that's a serious answer.
I'm like, oh yeah, he's nine.
That is a serious answer. It is.
And so I'm like, oh yeah, that's, that's a big deal.
Let's look that up. And so I looked it up on Google
and I said, you're right, gray, uh, Joey Chestnut,
he ate 83 hot dogs in 10 minutes.
Like that's incredible. That's incredible.
That's not just the hot dog
with the butt, it's the bun also.
Yeah, it's the soaked in water.
And, and really that's the difference between us
and God.
Jesus upholds galaxies,
and we are upholding hot dogs in comparison.
So we don't share
or reflect God's attributes to the same degree that he does.
And that's the point here. We reflect his attributes truly
but faintly while he possesses
them limitlessly.
So think of it like this. When scripture calls us
to holiness or love
or justice, it's calling us to reflect
who God already is.
Leviticus 11, again, be holy
for I am holy, so be holy.
Or Ephesians five, one, be imitators
of God as beloved children.
So be imitators of God.
And these passages imply that God's character must be
admirable and also imitable
to some measure, so admirable and imitable.
And that's why we divide attributes into
two broad categories.
We saw last week that incommunicable attributes remind us
that God is utterly unique.
He's utterly distinct. He alone is infinite.
He alone is eternal. He alone is unchangeable.
He alone is omnipresent. He's everywhere.
He alone is self existent.
The theological term for that is asity.
And he alone is all powerful.
He's sovereign, and those are his
incommunicable attributes.
And now we have communicable attributes.
So communicable attributes show us what it means to
display his attributes, his image in the world.
And so here's, here's a quick comment for you.
This division communicable incommunicable, this,
it's not an absolute division.
Some qualities that we see here tonight, like spirituality,
indivisibility, they kind of sit on the edge of categories.
There's some fuzzy ness to those boundaries.
So the label doesn't really matter, but,
but that we, it matters what that we rightly understand
every attribute.
So in this section, I want you to see
that God's perfections are not abstract ideas.
They are revelations of his character,
and they always come with a plea
and ask to respond like we respond
because of these attributes.
And that means that the, our study tonight
of attributes is really an invitation to worship
this theology that leads to doxology.
And one more important theological note, uh,
there's this term called modern retrieval work,
which basically is, um, going back to,
uh, historic Christianity for some of the theological ideas
that were cemented back then
because of modern retrieval work.
There's been a lot of emphasis lately that God is not
a collection of traits.
And I'm sure this has already been addressed in this class,
but God is not a collection of traits,
but because of divine simplicity.
I think that might be in your definition list
because of divine simplicity,
which I think Grudem calls Grudem is the author of
Bible doctrine and systematic theology.
I think that grudem calls it unity.
It's more commonly known as divine simplicity,
that God's attributes are not building blocks,
but God is his attributes.
God is his attributes.
And I've heard it described like this, that if God isn't
five pounds of holiness and five pounds of justice
and five pounds of love, you know, he, he is love.
He is justice, he is wrath.
And every attribute is a qualification on
every other attribute.
So that means that his love, his holy love, his justice,
his loving justice, his wrath, his righteous wrath.
So keeping in mind that God is his attributes helps us
to see his attributes as different angles
on the same God.
It's divine simplicity.
So one more note here, some other large words,
anthropomorphism are places in scripture that use
human form language for God,
for instance, the hand of the Lord.
And then there's another term while anthropopathism
use human emotion, words like love
and jealousy, wrath and delight.
God uses anthropomorphism
and anthropopathism
to help us understand his infinite nature.
So when we hear God is love
or God is jealous,
we must remember we are hearing true words.
Those are absolute truths,
but they are in
that analogical words like they're analogies,
God's perfection expressed in categories
that we can understand.
And so this connects us.
Let's take another little bit of a tangent here.
This connects us to the classical doctrine
of divine impassability,
which Dan probably talked about last week.
This, uh, divine impassability is an important guardrail
to understand when we are talking about God's emotions.
So impassability means that God cannot be overcome
by passions or emotional changes from
outside forces like we are.
Somebody cuts us off in traffic or we get angry,
and that was an outside force acting on us,
nor is he, uh, nor is he watching.
He shared and he's pleased with us One moment,
and then we say a harsh word to one of our kids,
and then he, then he suddenly burns with anger over
what we just did in response, what we just did.
That's not how it works.
His love, his wrath
and jealousy are not
reactive involuntary feelings.
So instead, God's emotions are active
and voluntary expressions of his unchanging character.
Remember, he is immutable, he is unchanging.
So he is love.
He doesn't fall into love.
His wrath is his settled
constant righteous opposition to sin,
not an uncontrolled fit of rage.
So this is distinct from the sun.
Jesus Christ, who in his humanity
was passable his humanity.
He was passable, he truly could
and did suffer hunger, sorrow and pain for our salvation.
All right, let's jump into the attributes we have a lot.
Let's continue on here.
So his attributes de describing god's being,
let's begin with those.
So the first is spirituality.
If God made the universal, what is he made of then?
Um, is, does he have flesh and bones like us?
Can the one who filled heaven
and earth, can he be contained by space in some way?
Can the creator be another creature among creatures?
Can he be measured in dimensions or detected by instruments?
No, scripture says that he is none of these.
It says very plainly in John 4 24 that God
is spirit.
God is spirit.
That means that he is not made of matter.
He has no parts, no dimensions.
He cannot, cannot be perceived
by our physical senses.
So not only can he not be perceived,
but his kind of existence is more excellent than
anything else in creation.
And this is why idolatry is so offensive to picture God
as an object or an image only serves to
diminish who he is.
So the second command we see forbids grave and images
because God's being is unlike
anything else in all of creation.
And I've heard it described this way,
God's being is categorically other.
He's not just bigger and better than our own being.
He is categorically other.
So again, our language about God, we,
we talked about it earlier, it's
therefore it's, it's analogical, it's analogy.
So when scripture speaks of God's hand
or his eyes, it is only giving us something
that we can understand.
Remember that? So that means
that anthropomorphic texts are true and they are fitting,
but there are not literal body parts to God.
Same chronicle 16, nine says, for the eyes of the Lord run
to and fro throughout the whole earth to give strong support
to those whose hearts are blameless beforehand.
And it's not his literal eyes
running to and fro.
Okay? So Jesus links God's spirituality to how we worship
to the Samaritan woman, he says
that Father seeks worshipers in spirit and in what truth.
And it's not dependent on where we do it
or the quality of how we perform it.
So gospel centered worship, it's important to know,
is it's shaped by God's word.
It's empowered by the spirit. It's not image driven.
It's not chasing the, you know, sensations of some kind.
So spirituality does another thing in, in that it clarifies
what we are as his image bearers.
We have spirits and know and love and, and will.
And by the Holy Spirit, we are united to Christ in a bond
that's more real than sight.
One Corinthians one, uh, six 17 says that we're joined
to the Lord and we become one spirit with him.
So in death, believers are away from body
and at home with the Lord.
And that presumes as you would expect, that
there is a spiritual presence
before a bodily resurrection.
And that should encourage us to persevere in suffering
because fellowship with God does not depend on any kind
of material or physical circumstance.
Okay? So that's attribute one, spirituality.
The second is invisibility. Invisibility.
And so the first question automatically for most would be
how can, how can invisibility be communicated?
And every kid on the planet would be like,
well, sign me up for that.
I would love that. But let's think
through this for a second here.
John one 18 says that no one has ever seen God
verse Timothy six 16 calls him the one
who dwells in unapproachable light.
So that means God's essence cannot
be seen by our eyes either now or in glory.
We cannot. And yet God
still shows himself in visible ways.
And so we see that in the Old Testament
where he appeared in the offs.
What, what is it? The offing?
Who knows what a, the offing is
God showing up in person before Jesus.
Yeah, God showing up in a visible manifestation
before Jesus comes around, right?
That's exactly right. And Jesus effectively ends the
offings, right?
Um, and so
a theophany temporary visible manifestation of God,
God appeared in theophany
as we saw in the Old Testament angel of the Lord, a pillar
of cloud and fire, the glory cloud over the mercy sea.
And these manifestations are real revelations.
But are they complete?
No, they're not complete unveiling of
who God is, of God's being.
And we ultimately see that this supreme manifestation
is Jesus Christ himself.
The Son is the image of the invisible God.
And whoever has seen the son, has seen who the Father
in that incarnate revelation.
So most theologians would, would strip,
the theologian would stress that incarnation is not
a theo, but what would be called in in flesh.
So God in the flesh, eternal son, assuming
complete human nature without confusing natures
In Christ, we see that invisibility becomes saving
visibility where God makes himself noble, makes himself
near without cc to be God.
So how then will we see God in the age to to come?
I don't know about you, but I love Revelation 22.
Almost more than anything,
scripture promises this beatific vision
or says they shall see his face,
and yet even then we will not comprehend his essence,
exhaust of the incompletion in that moment.
So here again, we see, we talked about this earlier,
we see another beautiful anthropomorphism.
So seeing his face isn't about physical sight,
but a direct personal unhindered experience of God's glory.
God's glory in the face of Jesus Christ is the light
that transforms us from one degree glory to another.
So here's the takeaway from these,
these first two attributes, spirituality and invisibility.
God, his being is utterly done beyond creation,
and yet he graciously makes himself known to us.
He calls us to respond and worship,
and he calls us to live in hope
of seeing his face forever.
So now we turn onto the mental attributes is
another category here.
Mental attributes show God's perfect knowing, his wise
choosing his truthful speaking.
And the first attribute under that umbrella
of mental attributes is knowledge or omniscience.
And I know we just said omniscience
for incommunicable attributes.
Remember there's a little bit of fuzziness
around these categorizations.
So God's omniscience his perfect knowledge,
here's the definition of that God fully knows himself
and all things actual and possible in one simple
and eternal act.
What does that mean? That means first of all,
that he knows everything, everything that is
and everything that ever could.
He knows it all. Hebrews four 13 says, no, create,
no creature is hidden from his sight.
And I've, I've heard it described this way that that
that truth can be a profound comfort to us.
And it can be a holy terror.
It's a comfort because your life is never miscalculated
by a loving God.
But it's also a terror
because no secret sin escapes his gaze.
Second, God knows all this in one simple and internal act.
So he isn't some Google supercomputer that has
to look things up or learn.
Now he knows everything all at once
from all eternity.
He never learns and he never forgets.
And it's a very different way of saying what you might say
of some, some guy like that guy he never learns.
No, it's he never learns because he knows it all.
So how do we imitate this?
So since knowledge is a communicable attribute, we're called
to reflect it.
And so we do this by pursuing true knowledge.
We renew our minds with scripture
and we grow in the knowledge of God who already knows us.
Perfect. Second mental attribute is wisdom.
So if God's knowledge is knowing all the facts
and wisdom is the perfect skill of applying them.
And the definition is this, God always
chooses the best goals and the best means to those goals.
So we see this wisdom displays supremely at the cross where,
uh, what looked like foolishness
to the world was actually God's plan of redemption.
And we see it working in the lives of our, of the promise
of Romans 8 28, where God is masterfully
weaving together all things, even suffering
for our ultimate good,
to make us more like Jesus for his glory.
And so since wisdom is a communicable attribute,
we can grow in it.
We can, we imitate it when we ask God for wisdom, knowing
that it gives it generously.
Almost every single elder meeting, we, we pray
to God asking for wisdom.
And what does Proverbs say?
The beginning of wisdom is Proverbs nine 10 says, the fear
of the Lord is the beginning of what is wisdom.
So the fear of the Lord is a, a reverent awe, the desires
to honor him in all we do.
And that is where wisdom begins.
So finally, when, when we can't understand his wisdom in our
circumstances, our call is simple.
We trust and we obey.
So we are to not lean on our own understanding.
Scripture says, but on our faithful creator who's infinitely
wise, the third mental attribute is truthfulness,
including faithfulness.
It's part of, uh, part of the truthfulness attribute
to God is the true God.
All all of his knowledge
and word to true he is the final standard of truth.
He's faithful keeps his promises.
We imitate this by loving truth, by hating falsehood,
guarding our speech.
We'll move on to moral attributes.
I'm I'm follow a little bit behind.
So I'm gonna kind of pick up the pace, uh, moral attributes.
So now we we're at moral attributes.
We show God's goodness, his love, holiness,
justice, jealousy, and wrath.
And the first is goodness, which under goodness has
the umbrella, uh, including mercy and grace.
So God is the final standard of good.
All he does is worthy of approval.
James one 17 says, every good gift, every perfect gift
comes from above coming down from the father of lights
with whom there is no variation or shadow due to change.
And so we see that he is good and he is unchanging.
He is unchanging good.
And from the beginning God declared his works
to be very good.
One of my favorite Psalms in Psalm 84
or says He withholds no good thing from those
who walk uprightly.
And this goodness isn't some, uh, abstract con concept.
It's an active benevolence to his people.
And we see mercy and grace under this umbrella as well.
And you know, mercy
and grace, mercy is his goodness toward those who
are in in misery and distress.
Grace is his goodness toward those
who only deserve punishment.
You've heard the the shorter definitions.
Mercy is not giving people what they deserve.
And grace is giving people what they don't deserve.
And both are seen in Exodus 34, 6, it's where it says
he is a God, merciful
and gracious, slow to anger, bounding in steadfast love.
And so his love is this steadfast love.
You've heard the, uh,
Hebrew word has said it's a steadfast
love that he has for us.
It's a love that does not let go.
And so we also see God's goodness
demonstrated in things like, uh, common grace.
Who knows what common grace is as a term?
Everyone, sorry everyone, whatever you want.
It doesn't matter if you're a believer or unbeliever it.
Uh, it's Justin. Yeah, yeah, absolutely rains.
Sun, rain just unjust, doesn't matter.
And so when his, when what God has
provided seems severe, his heart remains good.
And how do we imitate this?
Well, we imitate this by doing good to all,
especially to who?
To those in the household of faith.
Mercy begins by seeing
and drawing near to those who are suffering.
Grace looks like forgiving the undeserving
and giving beyond what can be given back.
We practice it in truth and justice.
Uh, we're kind to people as he's kind to us, knowing
that kindness is meant to lead us to repentance.
And that is his goodness. Second moral attribute is love.
And first John, we see this
powerful statement about God's character when it says God
is love.
And again, we know that to mean that it is in concert with
in fullness with every other attribute.
So it's not crowding out his other attributes.
God eternally gives of himself to others.
And this love existed forever within the trinity
and then it was shown to us.
And his love is radical 'cause it moved.
First one John four 10 says this, in,
in this is love.
Not that we have loved God, but that he loved us.
And how is his love ultimately, ultimately proven?
Well, his love is proven on the cross.
Romans five eight declares, God shows his love for us
and that while we were still centered, he died for us.
Christ died for us, was an act of holy love in
that moment, satisfying God's justice in order
to give us the greatest gift possible.
So as his children we're called
to imitate this self-giving love.
And so we love God back through obedience to his commands.
We love others through a costly, practical form of love.
Not just with Word but indeed
and in truth the
third moral attribute.
Holiness. Holiness.
And so, uh, this is one of those, this is one
of those attributes that um, people often list first,
which I probably would again, not that it's
the most dominant in some cases,
but it is the umbrella attribute.
It colors every other attribute.
God's holiness means that he is both holy other, again,
W-H-O-L-Y, holy other, he's transcendent,
he's set apart, he's incomparable
and he is also the one who calls us to be holy.
As he's holy God is separated from sin
and he is devoted to his own honor.
And so holiness
includes separation from evil
and devotion to God.
That's what holiness looks like.
And this vision that we see, the sfo crying, holy, holy,
holy in Isaiah six
emphasizes this infinite transcendence.
And Peter echoes Leviticus be holy, for I am holy.
And this is a, a call to us to be, uh, ethical
and holy and set apart.
So in this sense, holiness gathers up
all the other attributes.
His love is holy love. His justice is holy justice.
His mercy is holy mercy.
And so he causes people to be a holy nation
set apart to him.
And so we see that holiness is both a status granted
and it's also a calling to pursue.
We pursue holiness by resisting sin
and by devoting ourselves to his glory.
And this isn't optional, holiness isn't optional.
It is the necessary evidence of belonging to God.
Holiness functions as a distinguishing mark
of god's being.
And a it's a call. It's a full call to his people.
The fourth moral attribute we see is righteousness
or justice.
You see those two talked about in tandem.
So what does this mean? God always acts in accordance with
what is right and he himself is the final standard for
what is right.
That means he must punish sin
or else he would be unrighteous.
And the cross shows that he is righteous.
Jesus bore our punishment for sin so
that God could be just and a justifier.
And RC Spro
clarified that true justice is giving each their due.
And so there's a interesting diagram.
I saw him draw and I'll, I'll try to draw it.
Um, where it talks about, if you imagine justice,
this might help us
understand this a little bit better.
So we have justice, everything within this
circle is justice.
Outside of the circle is what you would call
non justice
makes sense, justice and non justice.
But within the category of non justice,
there's two halves to this.
So we see two halves
Here
And on this side we see injustice,
which is against the heart of God and we see
grace and mercy.
I thought that was a helpful view
to understand how God works.
Grace and mercy stand outside of his justice.
But we see later,
and we saw it already in Exodus 34, how he
is just and has to be just his very character,
his very character.
He is justice.
And so this attribute
of righteousness
or justice gives us hope that the judge of the earth will do
what is right and uh,
and fear really knowing that he will not
by any means clear the guilty.
So we imitate his justice.
When we act with fairness, with integrity, with equity,
when we defend the oppressed, we judge Without partiality
we show mercy and without abandoning truth.
The fifth moral attribute is jealousy. Jealousy.
And so God continually, continually seeks
to protect his own honor.
And unlike human jealousy which is rooted in pride,
God's jealousy is right
because he alone deserves all worship.
And this is a perfect outworking of the earlier term.
His impassability, his impassability.
It's not a reactive insecure passion,
but a righteous and a settled
and a constant expression of his unchanging character.
So he imitated jealousy when we are zealous for his glory
and we are offended when he is dishonored.
So that is jealousy. Sixth moral attribute is wrath.
God intensely
hates sin.
Romans one, the wrath
of God is revealed from heaven against all ungodliness
and unrighteousness of men who
by their unconsciousness suppressed the truth.
And so if you recall God's impassability,
we know this wrath isn't an uncontrolled rage
but is holy and it's constant
and it is a settled opposition, evil.
And we see that wrath is the flip side
of his holiness and is justice.
And we thank God for his wrath
because of God who does not hate sin, wouldn't be worthy
of worship for believers, Christ
has born God's wrath on our behalf.
It says Jesus who delivers us from the wrath to come
and we imitate his wrath.
Not by personal vengeance, but by hating.
Hating evil
and injustice while showing
mercy to sinners.
So here's the takeaway.
God's moral perfection show us what is right, pure and good
and by the spirit we are being conformed
to his likeness in these very attributes.
Alright, attributes of purpose.
Purpose and these display God's willing, his deciding,
his empowering of all things.
The first is will
and the definition of will is the ability to decide and act.
So God's will is that by which he approves
and determines to bring about every action necessary
for himself and all creation.
We read in Ephesians one who he works
all things according to the council of his will.
In scripture, God's will is the ultimate
reason for what exists.
What occurs creation itself is by his will.
Revelation four 11, worthy are you owe our Lord
and God to receive glory and honor
and power for you, created all things
and by your will they existed
and were created by your will.
Even the events surrounding Jesus' death came about like
God's hand and plan.
And this surprises some Acts 4 27
through 28 it says, is
your holy servant Jesus, whom you anointed both pared
and conscious Pilate along with the gentiles
and the peoples of Israel to do whatever your hand, God,
whatever your hand and your plan had predestined
to take place that paints a picture of Jesus' death
being at the hand and plan of God.
Our daily planning is also humbly
conditioned by his will.
James four 15. I love this verse.
The passage is talking about all these plans that we want
to make, want to go and do and accomplish and achieve.
And it says in James four 15 it says, instead you ought
to say, if the Lord wills, we will live
and do this or that.
And notice the phrase, we will live
our living and even our breathing
hang on his will.
When we talk about God's will,
it's important this distinguish revealed will from secret
will God's revealed will gives his commands
and is to be obeyed.
Your will be done.
And God's secret will is his decree of what shall be often
only after, after it occurs.
And holding both of those together keeps us responsible
in obedience while trusting in his sovereignty.
I my everybody calls those two types
of wills, different things.
My favorite way of calling those wills are will of command
and will of decree.
It's a little bit more descriptive than me,
it's easier for me to remember.
Will of command is simple, it's like his will is
that you're obedient to his command in scripture.
What does he command? It will of decree is I have
decreed this to be, I've declared this to be.
And so therefore it happens.
Isaiah 46 says, says I am God
and there is no other I'm God.
And there's none like me declaring
the end from the beginning
and from ancient times things not yet done.
That is decreeing what is going to happen.
And he is declared everything.
God's freedom means that he does whatever he pleases
and that is consistent with his holy character.
Second, second attribute here under attributes
of purpose, omnipotence am gonna pick it up.
Sorry. God's omnipotence means that he can do all of this.
Holy will scripture says, is anything too hard for the Lord?
No, nothing is with God. All things is are possible.
He's able to do far more than we can ask or think.
And his sovereignty is his active rule.
He works all things according to counsel.
Counsel of his will and his power never
contradicts his character, cannot lie,
cannot be tempted by evil.
He cannot deny himself.
And this kind of power that he exemplifies is not
what you would classify as an absurd power.
It's not an unreasonable crazy power.
So it's attributes of purpose.
Things are not ra random God's wise, ordering of all things
and his holy power secures his purposes.
Our calling is to obey his revealed will
to trust his secret, will to trust his decreed will,
and then to participate in Christ's life and mission.
I'll really go quickly through this David
summary attributes, what time, what you want,
summary attributes.
And these gather up fullness of God perfections
into a few descriptions here.
The first is perfection.
God completely, completely possesses all excellent
qualities and lacks nothing desirable.
He is fully perfect. Nothing is missing.
We imitate this by pursuing maturity to be perfect.
How daunting is that? To be perfect
as your father is perfect means to strive for wholehearted
holiness across all of life.
Second summary attribute blessedness.
God delights fully in himself
and in all that reflects his character.
He's not restless, not needy,
he's perfectly happy in himself
and his delight spilled over onto us.
The third summary.
At beauty we see that God
is the sum of all desirable qualities.
We see that in Psalm 27, 4.
One thing have I asked of the Lord that will I seek
after that I may dwell in the house of the Lord
all the days in my life to gaze upon the beauty
of the Lord and to inquire in his temple.
Beauty is this positive side of perfect is not.
It's not just lacking nothing,
but it's possessing everything that is desirable.
And so we imitate this by loving the beauty of holiness.
When we behold his beauty, scripture talks about this,
we are changed or changed.
So to summarize the summary attributes, God is the fullness
of all excellence.
Perfect, blessed, beautiful.
So to conclude here, what have we seen?
What do we know? God's communicable attributes are not
abstract ideas, but rather they are His
character revealed.
He is admirable
and he is imitable, admirable and imitable.
We have a memory verse today
and it's one we've already covered,
but I want you now to see
and appreciate these words as we, as I read through them.
And I want you to identify your heart, your mind,
those communicable attributes as I go through this.
Exodus 34, 6, 7.
The Lord passed before him
and proclaimed the Lord, the Lord a God, merciful
and gracious, slow to anger,
abounding in steadfast love
and faithfulness, keeping steadfast love for thousands,
forgiving iniquity and transgression and sin.
But who will by no means clear the guilty.
How does this point to Christ Jesus?
We hold the glory of God, we behold it.
It's full of grace and truth. Echoing love and faithfulness.
John one 14 says this,
and the word became flesh wealth among us.
And we have seen His glory.
Glory as of the only son from the Father full
of grace and truth.
So we imitate this by pursuing all of these
we're merciful, gracious, we're patient,
we're steadfast in love, we're truthful, we're forgiving.
We're just, we don't compromise righteousness.
My final word for you to carry as you
go home tonight, when we behold
God's communicable attributes,
We see not only what he is like,
but also what we're called to become.
Let's pray. Father, we thank you
that you have shown us your glory in your word
and in Christ we confess we are slow to believe.
We're quick to wander.
Your mercy is tender and it is greater than our weakness.
Your love is steadfast.
Help us to walk in holiness, to speak truth,
to show mercy to live in love,
to teach us to trust your will, lean on your power
and to rest in your blessedness and your beauty.
Help us as we reflect your glory. In Jesus name pray. Amen.
Amen.
Alright, so here's the participation part of it.
Everybody's got participation. So here we go.
What we have is everybody remember Muhammad Ali?
No. Champion me there.
Say one time he was getting on an airplane fixing the head
out to another fight and uh, the steer just comes by
and said, sir, please open your buckle on.
Buckle up your seatbelt. Okay.
He says, ah, Superman don't need no no be
Yeah, but Superman don't need no flame.
She says. So here we go.
You might go at all, you might be holding more
hot dogs up than in rest of us for a buckle up.
Get to the game and participate. I want you to talk out.
I do have a rhetorical question for you first,
but first I'm gonna call on my three Paul brothers.
So I need you to look up, uh, captain Paul,
please look up Romans 9 21, uh, piano Paul
from Joshua 24 15 and two dogs St.
Corinthians five 20.
Your reportal question is,
how is God like us?
If he's invisible.
I know right now he's invisible
'cause he's made everything I was going talk about tonight
invisible in my head.
I can't see. Alright, so here we go.
We're gonna talk about invisibility.
How in the world does that relate to us? Let's see.
What Gruden has states says God's total essence,
all his spiritual being can never be seen by us.
Yet God still shows himself to us through visible
and created things.
It's invisible, but we can see him through those things.
God's invisibility means God himself decides
to whom he's gonna reveal himself from.
Matthew 1127.
God's invisibility means that we must daily,
intentionally seek after fellowship with him
and not take it for granted.
Jeremiah 29 13.
So the human beings, we as human beings, we're both a
creature and a person.
Correct? So
to be a creature means to completely
depending on God.
We completely depend on him.
All creatures do correct, but we're a person.
And give us a definition of that.
Being a person means we're related.
Independence or our ability to choose. We have a choice.
We can choose things, right?
He gave us a a ability to reason.
Self-determination. So here's the mystery we have.
How can you, whether a guy or girl, can you be a creature
and a person, someone who's totally dependent on God,
but somebody, a person who gets to make decisions.
God will. God will. Okay.
How, what does that look like from the Bible?
Can anybody tell me what, how do we see that in the Bible?
Genesis Okay. Being
Made from the earth, the, the, the dust of the earth.
Okay, so good. Captain Paul, read your regards please.
Romans 9 21 has the potter no right over the clay
to make out of the same month.
One best for honorable use and another for dishonorable use.
God it a dish honor, we are a creature
who made this correct.
Okay, now, uh, piano, Paul Joshua 24 15.
And if it is evil in your eyes to serve the Lord, choose
to stay who you'll serve.
Whether the gods of the Father served in a region
beyond the river or the gods of the Amorites
in whose land you dwell.
But as for me in my house, we'll serve the Lord
God. We have a choice
to serve God
or not to serve God as you person, as a creature.
You remain by God. You determin tell. Alright? Uh, two dogs.
Therefore we are ambassadors of Christ, God making his
for us and implore you on behalf Christ
and reconcile for God.
Corinthians by.
So we're creatures but we're made to do his work.
He wants us to work hard to glorify him. Correct?
Okay, so here's our second one.
Since you are a creature, you can only be saved by grace.
That is complete dependence on
God, on God's mercy.
Right? Have the fact that you are also a person means
that you have an essential role to play
in the process of redemption.
Very responsibility in the process of salvation.
What is your role in the process of salvation?
Succeed it. Receive it.
What, what, what, what, what does that entail?
Okay. Is there a part in there where, uh,
that's half of it, right?
What's the other half? Repentance. Repentance. Perfect.
You must choose the empowered
and be empowered by the Holy Spirit to repent of sin
and believe in the Lord Jesus Christ.
But mouth Jesus.
Believe in your heart you'll be saved.
And belief. And what's
that's we go look at people, be baptized,
be the profession of it.
Correct. So another question now, more of application.
How do you pursue fellowship with God instead?
Because we talked about fellowship back up here, right?
Where God's in disability means that we must daily,
intentionally seek after fellowship with you
and not take it for granted.
'cause he is invisible. We need to seek that fellowship.
How are you doing that? Can somebody gimme an example?
You personally?
Good. Anyone else?
Reflecting God's glory. Good. And doing how you do that?
By loving is he loves caring as he cares. Forgives us.
He forgives good. Yeah.
In the way you do relationship with others. Very good.
Anyone else reading a word but then chewing on it? Good.
Good. Actually reasoning and thought process that he gave.
Set up. There we go.
Alright, I have one more question just
off the top of my head.
I don't have permission for my elders,
so it's not his fault all on me.
Okay. So if you hear someone say
everyone's a child of God, is that correct?
No.
Creature created God. Very good. Very good.
So we're all creatures.
We're all created in the image of God,
but we're not all children of God
until we accept Christ in their heart.
Right? Adopted. Very good. Thank you guys.
Thank you David. Appreciate you.
Uh, what do you wanna do? Paul? Just go or, uh, I think so.
Yeah. Another hall I just renamed you Paul. Thank y'all.
Thanks guys. Have a good one. So we're set. We're all good.
We're sent, we're good to go. We are sent, we are sent.
I, woo. I got for you. Okay.